[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale nous sommes le jeudi
7 janvier voici les titres de cette
édition
la confirmation a été donnée à la
mi-décembre l'ensemble des city vinoy
des jo-2000 24 a été retenu dans la
carte définitive de l'événement le
château de versailles à saint quentin en
yvelines le vélodrome le golf national
et la colline d'elancourt invité laurent
mazaury vice président aux sports de
saint quentin en yvelines et yvan clolus
entraîneur national de vtt à la
fédération française de cyclisme
les états unis vivent des heures sombres
alors que le congrès certifié l'élection
de joe biden à la présidence des
militants pro tron se sont introduits
cette nuit dans le capitole une femme a
même été tuées dans les heurts nous
verrons comment les américains des
yvelines ont vécu ces événements et le
premier ministre jean castex s'exprime
ce soir à propos du contexte sanitaire
il doit faire de nouvelles annonces
une chose est sûre les bars et
restaurants ne rouvriront pas le 20
janvier de quoi forcément suscité
l'inquiétude des professionnels du
secteur dans le département et nous vous
tiendront d'ailleurs à informer à la fin
de ce journal est des annonces des
principales annonces à retenir du
gouvernement
l'information du jour au niveau local
elle nous vient de poissy la commune a
inauguré à cet après midi son centre de
vaccination contre le kobe de 19
c'est le premier en france hors hôpitaux
est nommé chez maurice est en référence
à la première personne vaccinée en
france il est installé dans le bâtiment
du centre de diffusion artistique de la
ville
ce site avait déjà été transformé lors
du premier confinement en un lieu de
consultation puis de dépistage le centre
de vaccination s'adresse dans un premier
temps aux soignants pompiers et aides à
domicile de plus de 50 ans sur rendez
vous les inscriptions se font notamment
via d'octo libre écoutez le maire de
poissy interrogé par justine brasier
comment on va gérer les doses de la
veille pour le lendemain on sait que le
jour j on a 150 personnes à vacciner 150
divisé par cinq
on a le nombre de doses à aller chercher
à versailles à l'hôpital de versailles
pourquoi parce que c'est le centre pivot
départementale qui lui va le cas échéant
acheminé à l'hôpital de poissy et nous
nous allons aller avec un camion
frigorifique de la ville de poissy
chercher ces doses vous arrivez ici vous
êtes enregistré consultation pré
vaccinale vaccination enregistrement des
données
une demi heure d'attenté pour voir s'il
n'y a pas d'effets secondaires
et puis vous ressortez tranquillement et
le centre sera également ouvert d'ici la
fin janvier aux personnes âgées de plus
de 75 ans plus que trois ans désormais
avant les jeux olympiques en france est
bonne nouvelle pour les sites civils
noix de paris à 2024 ils ont été tous
confirmés par le comité d'organisation
le département accueillera au total
cette discipline sportive dont le
cyclisme sur piste et le vtt ou encore
l'équitation les détails dans ce sujet
de michael ni d'euros c'est officiel les
yvelines vont accueillir cette
discipline sportive pendant les jo de
les sites ont été définitivement adoptée
le 17 décembre dernier par le comité
d'organisation versailles organisera le
cyclisme sur route à proximité du
château ainsi que des épreuves de
pentathlon moderne la ville royale
recevra également les épreuves
d'équitation un temps pressenti à la
mode devront nous on savait que toutes
les chances étaient avec nous parce que
faire un site totalement exceptionnel
grâce au château de versailles vient
bien sûr qu'ils accueillent et puis
l'environnement donc oui c'est une
occasion formidable à saint quentin en
yvelines le vélodrome nationale
accueillera bien le cyclisme sur piste
et recevra les preuves des scream du
pentathlon moderne à une centaine de
mètres les courses de bmx seront
organisées enfin le golf national
recevra les épreuves golfique six ans
seulement après la ryder cup 2018
ce qu'est le bien par rapport aux jeux
olympiques ce que ça va toucher
certainement une environ public un petit
peu plus large que la ryder cup parce
qu'alors hiller cup
peut-être que ça a touché uniquement un
public d'avertis de golfeurs alors que
les jeux olympiques
peut-être touché délai les personnes qui
peut-être sont pas susceptibles de
penser au wolf
alors en tant qu'activité olympique
enfin la colline d'elancourt et ses 230
mètres d'altitude accueillera les
épreuves de vtt en 2024
une nouvelle attendue depuis de longs
mois par le bce skyteam vous sert le
club local qui organise chaque année la
revancharde une compétition cycliste sur
le site
c'est nous on n'aurait pas ce que ça
fait 25 ans bai qu'on est sur ce terrain
là il a fait la première revancharde
on est les seuls utilisateurs qui vont
nous vtt ici en compétition et pour nous
c'est une grande réussite c'est un
bonheur un bonheur partagé par tous les
adhérents du club les yvelines sont
aussi hautes de 2 sites paralympiques le
para équitation sera programmée dans le
parc du château de versailles est élevé
le taux national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les épreuves de paracyclisme sur piste
et une grande partie de ces épreuves
cinq plus précisément seront accueillis
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines notamment pour le vtt sur la
colline d'elancourt on en parle avec mes
deux invités tout d'abord en plateau
laurent mazaury bonsoir bonsoir vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines délégué au score et
lui également et maire adjoint de la
ville d'elancourt et en visioconférence
yvan clolus bonsoir bonsoir de la
fédération française de cyclisme vous
êtes entraîneur national vtt
cross-country également coordinateur de
la filière vtt pour la direction
technique nationale de la fff c'est déjà
une première réaction avec vous laurent
mazaury l'ensemble des sites saint
quentinois confirmés dont notamment la
colline d'elancourt on le sait qui a été
un temps menacées mise en concurrence
avec le site de chamonix dans les alpes
comment l'agglomération at elle
accueilli du coup cette confirmation
avec grand plaisir et puis avec le
sentiment que la logique a été respectée
merci d'ailleurs à nos compétiteurs ces
deux obligé d'être à être encore
meilleurs dans notre projet mais je
pense que la logique est à 100% avec
nous nous sommes proches de marine se
bat 20 minutes de paris c'était logique
que les jeux olympiques de paris et de
saint quentin en yvelines bien entendu
cela ait lieu sur la colline elle en
cours même si elle un petit doute
l'optimisme régnait tout de même oui
l'optimisme régnait parce qu'on était
sûr de notre candidature sûre de la
qualité du dossier est sûr que le
l'accueil de l'encours était le meilleur
site pour recevoir dans quatre jeux
olympiques de paris les épreuves de vtt
ils vont peut lui sur la confirmation de
ce site de la colline d'elancourt on le
précise pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
ce site qui est située à quelques
kilomètres seulement de siège de la
fédération française de cyclisme qui est
implantée au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
comment vous l'avez accueilli cette
confirmation de sites pour la colline
pas déjà c'est vrai que c'est un
soulagement parce que ça fait plusieurs
années qu'on était un petit peu dans la
certitude et finalement maintenant les
choses vont venir vite donc c'est un
soulagement aussi par rapport à d'autres
projets de fédéral c'est vrai que
d'avoir l'ensemble des disciplines
autour de 5 ans
c'est ce qui était logique depuis le
départ c'est un soulagement aussi pour
les athlètes parce que je pense que pour
leurs jeux en france il avait à coeur
aussi des en région parisienne donc
voilà maintenant on y voit plus clair on
va pouvoir parler un petit peu plus
peut-être des détails du parcours après
mais en tout cas c'est un réel
soulagement pour tout le monde on va
parler de ce dossier dans un instant
laurent maso reid
il ya aussi des derniers ajustements qui
pourrait être fait sur les sites saint
quentinois notamment en ce qui concerne
le bmx il était prévu de construire à la
base une piste de bmx à lille de loisirs
saint quentin en yvelines
alors pourquoi puisque le stadium de bmx
du vélodrome dispose d'un toit et ça ça
pose des problèmes notamment pour les
retransmissions télévisées finalement
ils se pointent les épreuves de bmx et
bien lieu dans ce stadium de bmx qui est
à côté du vélodrome en tout cas vous
travaillez sur cette solution avec le
comité d'organisation tout à fait d'une
part d'un point de vue économique ça
semble faire sens et puis d'un point de
vue images c'est fabuleux même si on
aurait été accueillis on aurait
accueilli dans l'île de loisirs avec
plaisir aussi le l'activité bmx mais je
pense que le le le bmx tel qu'il a été
conçu je le rappelle en 2012 pour les
jeux olympiques en tout cas de paris
les meilleurs sites pour les recevoir
donc il reste un problème technique est
bien entendu un aspect financier à gérer
qui est le l'après midi que cette
toiture dont nous mêmes les télévisions
de nous mêmes ce que j'ai la chance
d'être sous représentés sur 18 parfois
on est un peu gêné en matière de
captation mais en tout cas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui tient le
lead on a encore quelques temps on peut
encore changer les choses c'est pas la
partie la plus complexe le stade bmx
note il est très technique et donc je
pense que oui selon toute logique on
devrait rester sur le stade de bmx tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui une solution par
exemple d'enlever le toit temporairement
de cet aspect là il ya des aspects
également de travail possibles sur la
façon dont on fait bouger aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue technologique
certaines caméras on en est l'exemple
sur ce sur ce plateau par exemple on a
des partenaires d'ailleurs à
saint-quentin divine qui ont ces
technologies là pour d'autres typologie
de stade et donc on joue un petit peu
c'est les deux on devrait pour arriver à
voir une solution qui soit à la fois
économiquement viable mais également et
surtout qualitative pour le public qui
suivra sur le site mais surtout à la
télévision dans le monde entier avec
près de 4 milliards de téléspectateurs
l'ensemble de ces retransmissions
consacrées sur un site existant ce qui
va être le cas pour le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui accueillera le cyclisme sur piste et
elle également pardon
le pentathlon moderne en tout cas les
preuves des scream du pentathlon moderne
il ya aussi le golf national forcément
qui a déjà accueilli la razer cap ils
ont l'avantagé
ces deux structures le golf national le
vélodrome nationale d'avoir déjà dans
leur passé récent une expérience de
compétition internationale tout à fait
vous l'avez cité la ryder cup au golf
national
bien entendu les championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste qui ont eu lieu il
ya de cela 20 en trois ans ce sont des
lieux dans lequel à la fois la qualité
est présente au niveau des
infrastructures d'accueil était de
savoir faire des gens qui travaillent
sur place toute l'année et j'irai même
la qualité des bénévoles et la qualité
de l'agglomération de saint quentin
aisne évident pour les transports mais
également je le redis tous ces bénévoles
qui ont su travailler sur les champions
du monde des consuls trahi la ryder cup
avec la qualité d'accueil en sécurité en
qualité d'accueil pour les personnels
soient plus présents sur place et aussi
bien sûr pour les pour les sportifs
alors on revient au dossier de la
colline d'elancourt parler des
aménagements qui pourraient être
réalisées avant que lui est ce que déjà
il lui manque beaucoup à cette colline
d'elancourt pour devenir une piste
olympique
du point de vue du niveau on va dire de
cette piste non non il manquait rien en
terme de topographie l'idée c'est que
notre activité elle est là pour épouser
je dirais le terrain elle est pas du
tout là pour défigurer quoi que ce soit
donc on va on va utiliser ce qu'on a sur
place
cette colline assez ronde assez homogène
on montera au sommet a priori trois fois
en redescendre à on aura une aire
d'arrivée départ sur le côté et l'idée
c'est de réfléchir à la fois pour les
jeux le jour j en 2024
et puis de réfléchir à une valorisation
aussi tout le domaine pour pour la suite
c'est à dire pour l'utilisation et pour
les gens des yvelines et pour les gens
peut-être de toute l'île de france
en fait on réfléchit un peu à la
construction quasiment d'un vrai parc si
vous voulez pour tous les utilisateurs
mais les premières ébauches qu'on a
c'est qu'on aura vraiment quelque chose
de joli et qui va à mon avis faire
monter vraiment de plusieurs crans tout
le tout le site dont on va parler cet
aspect pérennité avec laurent mazaury si
on revient sur la piste olympique
on sera sur une boucle de 18 km c'est ça
ah non non non le creux soit un pic on
est sur une entre 3,6 et 4 km et donc
les athlètes tourner plusieurs fois et
donc en montant trois fois au sommet de
la colline ça nous donne un peu près un
dénivelé de 160 mètres autour donc ça
c'est pour l'aspect piste olympique
on le disait l'idée c'est aussi de lui
donner une pérennité on sait qu'il ya
des sites dans de précédents gillot qui
sont aujourd'hui totalement à l'abandon
on ne veut pas se diriger vers ce cas de
figure alors je crois que la candidature
de paris elle est en rupture avec tout
ce qui s'est fait au préalable avec
peut-être un parallélisme avec londres
parce que londres a su faire justement
cette chose là c'est à dire faire en
sorte que les jeux olympiques au delà de
l'aspect purement sportif soit également
le un vecteur d'aménagement territorial
fort et puissant et soit quelque chose
qui permette en gros 2 réalisé par
avance des investissements de toute
façon qui aurait dû avoir lieu dans le
long terme et donc le travail qui a été
fait sur saint quentin en yvelines il
est ce que l'on appelle de travail sur
l'héritage jeu mais l'héritage hakkar h
majuscule ça que ses pensées toutes les
épreuves pour le futur de l'aménagement
qu'elles vont réaliser et la colline
d'elancourt rentre totalement dans ce
cadre là comme l'a dit notre collègue de
lui s'il ya un instant il y aura là
pardon de la fédération française de
cyclisme c'est un lapsus révélateur
puisque c'est lui c'est y qui avaient
ils travaillent sur la partie tracé pour
la partie olympiques ça a été pensé pour
être effectivement et devenir un site
qui soit pérennisé pour une activité
sportive mais également un grand respect
de l'écologie pour que l'on suit on est
des utilisateurs des familles qui
viennent s'y promener et qu'on rende en
fait à la population ainsi qu'
aujourd'hui certes ouvert mais qui n'est
pas très accessible
certes qui est vert mais qui n'est pas
que des essences de qualité certes qui
est des zones humides mais qui n'est pas
haute valeur écologique et bien pour
faire en sorte que les valeurs
écologiques qu'il a aujourd'hui demeure
qu'elle soit étendue et calcus est
ouverte au plus grand nombre c'est dans
la c'est dans la substantifique moelle
de la pensée même de la candidature
d'origine d'utilisation de cette colline
derrière question très rapidement c'est
un projet aux environs de 10 millions
d'euros est ce qu'on a déjà un
calendrier qui était à lui on est il le
sait ça sera fait avant les jo de 2024
j'allais vous le dire tout à fait mon
général on n'a pas qu'on a un calendrier
qui est en cours d'établissement qu'on
finalisation entre autres avec la furie
des eaux qui va piloter l'ensemble on
n'est pas tout à fait sous pression
parce que jeu comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure on a incité déjà après et quand
même devrait aller à 75% et donc les 25
% qui restent on veut vraiment les
peaufiner pour qu'elle soit partie en
efficace
on sera au new times comme disent les
anglo saxons sans aucun souci merci
laurent mazaury vice-présidente
saint-quentin-en-yvelines également élu
à la commune d'el en cours et et merci à
yves oncle lui qui était avec nous par
visioconférence de la fédération
française de cyclisme
dans l'actualité c'était il ya six ans
jour pour jour le 7 janvier 2015 12
personnes de la rédaction de charlie
hebdo était assassiné par deux
terroristes
une folie meurtrière qui s'était
poursuivie également le lendemain avec
l'assassinât par un autre individu d'une
policière à montrouge et de quatre
personnes à l'hyper catcheur à paris une
vague d'attentats qui avaient été mus
rappelez-vous en france des hommages
avait eu lieu dans plusieurs villes des
yvelines et notamment vous le voyez sur
ces images un rambouillet ou dix mille
personnes avaient marché contre la
barbarie avec des messages je suis
charlie dans le cortège
le 6 janvier 2021 dans l'histoire
restera également dans l'histoire
également celle des états unis des
centaines de militants de donald trump
ont manifesté devant le capitole avant
de s'introduire dans le bâtiment le site
a été envahie au moment même où était
certifié l'élection présidentielle de
joe biden est des images qui ont choqué
de nombreuses personnes dans le monde et
notamment les américains qui vivent dans
les yvelines les détails de nicolas
landry
ce devait être le jour de l'élection
officielle de joe biden réunis au
congrès les sénateurs et représentants
américains devaient certifier les
résultats du scrutin présidentiel de
2020 avec la victoire du candidat
démocrate
mais cela ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
le chaos s'est installé à washington
les militants du président donald trump
ont envahi le capitole je croyais pas
mes yeux
en fait les scènes hallucinantes sur les
listes et carrément choquant finalement
c'était des jamais vu depuis 1814 les
ces américains ont brisé les fenêtres du
bâtiment ont occupé et pillé des bureaux
d'élus puis se sont rendus dans les deux
chambres qui forment le congrès le coeur
du pouvoir législatif américain
je pense que joe biden a dit bien
il a dit c'est le site abel de la
démocratie c'est le seul dessein c'est
là où les lois du pays sont promulguées
c'est c'est juste inimaginable que ça
pue soulier à ce point ce sont des
imbéciles qui ont été dirigés par prince
incité par point de départ de ce
rassemblement devant le capitole un
discours du président donald trump
devant la maison blanche à la mi journée
nous pouvons descendre nous pouvons
descendre
ceux qui le désirent en direction du
capitole vous devez montrer votre force
et est trop fort face à cette situation
les représentants du parti républicain
en france n'ont pas encore réagi
il annonce vouloir se prononcer par
communiqué de presse
toujours un sujet international mais
avec des répercussions directement sur
l'économie blinoise le bric site est
effective depuis le 1er janvier 2021
le royaume uni ne fait donc plus partie
de l'union européenne et les deux
partenaires sur leurs relations
commerciales ont régi ont désormais
conclu un accord qui a été signé le 24
décembre de quoi impacté l'activité
outre-manche de certaines entreprises du
département exhorte exemple avec la
société axone qui est basée à trappes
avec nicolas landry c'est tout nouveau
pour nous mais désormais ces produits
sont fabriqués en france
à trappes il ya encore six mois nous les
importerons de grande bretagne
désormais nous préparons les réexporter
sur le marché britannique
c'est l'une des activités de cette
entreprise impactés par le break site la
fabrication de ces rampes d'accès pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
implantée à trappes axle a conçu cet
atelier de production en juillet 2020
après le rachat d'une société
britannique
l'atelier était en angleterre étaient
près de manchester effectivement une
société qui existait depuis 35 ans et
donc été amenée malheureusement a déposé
le bilan fin mars
fin mars 2002 or et nous étions leurs
plus gros clients or en uk
le dirigeant d'apple a préféré
internaliser cette production pour avoir
le contrôle
avec ensuite la volonté d'exporter au
royaume uni la difficulté pour lui en
janvier 2021 à quel prix peut-il vendre
ses produits
aujourd'hui vendre un particulier en
grande-bretagne pour moins de 135 livres
sterling c'est le particulier qui va
payer la tva plus de 135 livres sterling
celle l'exportateur qui payent la tva
plus les frais de transport qui vont
légèrement augmenter
autre impact pour cette entreprise sur
cette chaise d'évacuation pour personnes
en situation de handicap
axsun importe plusieurs de ses produits
auprès d'un fournisseur britannique des
biens à distribuer ensuite en france la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne va avoir quelques
conséquences
maintenant tout est organisé au niveau
des transportant en tout cas en ce qui
me concerne leurs systèmes ont été
modifiés donc les procédures de
déclaration dans ce sens qu'ils vont
être faites comment on fait déjà pour la
suisse où les autres pays hors union
donc en fait la belgique doit impliquer
donc plus de papier plus administratif
mais également des délais de livraison
plus long
cette société emploie 14 personnes
attrapées réalise 2 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires
c'est un rendez vous habituel du début
de l'année l'association yvelines
environnement a lancé son concours
annuel gratuit le thème en 2021 celui
des chauves-souris tous les participants
doivent remplir une grille de mots
autour de l'animal et illustrer le thème
nos amis les chauves-souris la
présidente divine
environnement présente les objectifs du
concours au micro de justin brasilia
plusieurs objectifs à ce concours il ya
l'information du public
l'information des structures dont je
vous ai parlé notamment l'éducation
nationale et cette nouvelle structure du
département et puis d'autre part la
connaissance d'un élément important si
vous voulez pour notre biodiversité et
troisièmement les visites de sites
particulièrement intéressant à l'aise au
niveau du département pour justement que
ceux qui ont participé soit mise en
contact avec des questions concrètes et
pour vous renseigner sur le thème vous
procure également un bulletin de
participation rendez vous sur le site
internet d'yveline environnement avant
le 7 avril et date limite de la
participation
suite et fin de notre fil rouge de la
semaine sur tv à 78 depuis lundi nous
revenions sur les événements qui ont
moins honte qui ont marqué 2020 dans les
yvelines année forcément marqué par
cette crise sanitaire l'émergence de
cette crise sanitaire et dernier voyage
dans le temps ce soir d'octobre à
décembre 2020 et c'est avec bixente mais
rien senti steban les habitants des
yvelines en deuil après l'assassinât de
samuel patick professeur d'histoire
géographie au collège du bois d'aulne de
conflent les hommages rendus dans tout
le département en particulier dans la
commune du drame
nous sommes ici à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans une ville
où il fait bon vivre
alors je dois dire aujourd'hui à mais
habitant cumul nous relèverons nous
relèverons tous ensemble après plusieurs
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
consécutifs dont un couvre-feu de 21h à
6h du matin le président de la
république
emmanuel macron a finalement annoncé un
recond films en général à compter du 29
octobre 2020 de nombreux magasins jugés
non essentiels ont donc été contraints
de fermer à nouveau leurs portes
jusqu'au 28 novembre
des mesures qui n'ont pas fait
l'unanimité en fait c'est passé avec les
librairies françaises souhaitée c'est
plutôt que nous on n'ouvre que
librairies indépendantes on roule parce
qu'on est tout à fait à même de savoir
gérer un flux de personnes dans une
librairie avec des jauges avec les
barrières sanitaires respecter contraint
de rester chez eux les yvelinois ont
adopté la livraison de colis
les commandes sur internet ont explosé
en témoignent les 35 mille colis par
jour livré sur le périmètre nord des
yvelines ce qui est beaucoup plus que je
contrôle devrait traiter normalement
avec la période de confinement c'est
environ + 28 % par rapport à ce qu'on
avait prévu initialement
après la démission de philippe benassaya
élu député de la 11e circonscription
jean-philippe luce a été nommé pour lui
succéder en tant que maire de bois
d'arcy
il a pris ses fonctions le samedi 7
novembre moi je suis évidemment fier et
ému de pouvoir aujourd'hui devenir mère
et être mère d'où tous les artisans pour
pour ce nouveau mandat
une page se tourne pour l' usine de
renault situé à flins le site
d'assemblage va se transformer en lieu
de recyclage et de reconditionnement
automobile la mutation sera totalement
achevée d'ici à 2024
le téléthon a également été modifié en
raison de l'impossibilité d'organiser
l'événement en présentiel
pas d'animation mais de la collecte
ainsi que des programmes numériques
au total huit cent trente six mille
euros de promesses de dons yvelinois ont
quand même été récoltés tout le long du
mois de décembre les yvelines mans
préparer les fêtes de fin d'année de
nombreux tests antigénique ont été faits
avant noël dans les pharmacies une
précaution nécessaire pour retrouver sa
famille dans les meilleures conditions
depuis deux jours j'ai que des résultats
négatifs la semaine dernière
les gens qui venaient en fait ils
avaient des symptômes ils avaient des
troubles ils se poser des questions donc
j'avais 5 10% de positif aujourd'hui
c'est que des gens qui veulent se
prévenir pour ne pas être contaminants
pendant le dîner de famille ils ont été
reconnus dans la france entière la
famille lefebvre a remporté la france a
un incroyable talent les huit versailles
et on est émerveillé les français de
leurs voix évidemment nos amis notre
entourage et ou à aimer ce qu'on fait il
doit soutenu surtout eu beaucoup de
retours ce soit en privé ou dans les
commentaires
j'ai découvert cette musique corse et un
crop je connaissais pas mais si c'est
magnifique ce que vous faites est donc
vraiment d'avoir fait découvrir cette
musique est l'accès y est plus et des
gens c'était vraiment super content
enfin c'est un beau cadeau de fin
d'année pour quatorze résidents
volontaires de l'ehpad mon repos de
sartrouville
l'établissement a accueilli la première
campagne de vaccination yvelinoise
contre la copie 19 le 31 décembre un
événement symbolique pour achever cette
année 2020 mais je vous le disais en
début d'édition le premier ministre jean
castex exprimé à partir de 18h ce soit
pour faire un point sur le contexte
sanitaire à l'heure où je vous parle
18h24 il ya déjà des choses à retenir
dans ses annonces concernant notamment
le variant anglais qui inquiète en
france notamment dans un contexte où le
nombre de contaminations que 8,19 reste
élevé 19 cas sont actuellement recensés
en france dont deux clusters et parmi
eux à ces deux clusters il y en a un qui
est située dans en ile-de-france pas
plus de précisions pour le moment de la
part du gouvernement
de ce fait dans les écoles la vigilance
sera renforcée dans les prochains jours
autre annonce à retenir pour les
activités culturelles pas de réouverture
envisagée pour le moment pour les
théâtres pour les cinémas également pour
les salles de spectacle un nouveau point
sera fait le 20 janvier pour évaluer la
situation le premier ministre qui n'a
parlé d'une réouverture pas avant la
mi-2010 las que l'on pouvait retenir et
même avant ces annonces une chose était
sûre et déjà confirmée par le
gouvernement
les bars et restaurants ne rouvriront
pas le 20 janvier ce ne devrait être pas
le cas avant la mi février a annoncé le
premier ministre jean castex le moment
donc tant attendu par les professionnels
du secteur est reportée de plusieurs
semaines au moins et l'inquiétude
grandit parmi les professionnels comme
l'ont constaté eléonore sinoquet et
bixente mariens autistes et ban
deux établissements yvelinois ce qu'on
attend surtout c'est une date de
réouverture c'est à dire une visibilité
tout le monde demande ça une visibilité
ce ne sera pas le 20 janvier comme il
l'avait tant espéré les restaurateurs
vont devoir une fois de plus prendre
leur mal en patience avant de pouvoir
accueillir à nouveau leur clientèle pas
une surprise pour certains on était déjà
préparé avec le rsa on sait qui on est
les premiers à souffrir des saints ont
fait que de l'emporter
et on a la charge et on faisait déjà
avant les fermetures pour la garde des
lieux clients et on a quelques sociétés
qui continuent de venir apprendre à
emporter pour franchement nous aider
pour tenir bon la vente emporté comme
maigre lot de consolation pour ce
restaurant de montigny le bretonneux
ce mode de fonctionnement été mis en
place à partir de décembre les plats
cuisinés de poissons notamment
on l'a fait comme je le disais tout à
l'heure en vente à emporter au mois de
décembre un petit peu un peu plus
fortement pour noël et jour de l'an
mais le total cela représente même pas
10% du chiffre d'affaires habituel
le seul intérêt de la vente à porter
pour nous c'est de rester présent dans
la tête de notre clientèle et puis sur
le plan commercial oscillent en plus du
chômage partiel qui couvrent 80 4% des
salaires l'état mis progressivement
d'autres est en place depuis octobre où
on a dix mille euros par mois ça arrive
un peu tard quand même c'est octobre
novembre décembre alors que sur toute
l'année 2020 on a été fermé pratiquement
six mois la moitié de l'année des
restaurants qui vont bientôt faire face
à deux échéances importantes
les congés payés accumulés tout au long
de l'année ainsi que les remboursements
des prêts garantis par l'état et nous
développerons les annonces du soir du
gouvernement dans deux prochaines
émissions sur tv 60,18 voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]